meanwhile German Chancellor Olaf Schultz
has arrived in Saudi Arabia at the start
of a two-day tour of the gulf Germany is
seeking new energy Partnerships after
the loss of Russian oil and gas supplies
Germany needs gas to heat homes and to
fuel industrial production
Russia's decision to cut gas supplies
means the search is on for alternative
sources that's why it's looking to the
mineral-rich countries of Qatar Saudi
Arabia and the United Arab Emirates the
Gulf States do have ample reserves and
natural gas it's quite cheap compared to
other sources and they are very very
trained and experienced in exporting
their gas liquefied natural gas or LNG
will be vital in meeting Germany's
energy needs Qatar has plenty but
there's a problem
Qatar in particular is a country that is
known to be mostly interested in
reliable and profitable business
relations matter is less interested in
being the guy to fill the Gap but
eventually Qatar is interested to become
a long-term supplier for Germany
committing to long-term contracts is
unattractive because Germany is
transitioning away from fossil fuels
for that reason Saudi Arabia might be a
more promising partner at the moment it
requires gas mainly for its own domestic
use but the Saudi government has set a
target of doubling gas production by
2030 yet political sensitivities could
prevent a deal
Saudi Arabia might demand Germany to uh
to to loosen or perhaps even to remove
uh its its arms export band that Germany
introduced uh particularly with regard
to the Yemen war that could lead the
United Arab Emirates as the most likely
partner for a gas deal the UAE might be
willing to offer Germany short-term gas
contracts here the difficulty is that
the infrastructure to export LNG does
not yet exist
this LNG export plans will need about
three to five years to be built so we
know how the market is going to look
like up to 2025 and the problem is that
there is not that much additional LNG
export capacity which is going to come
to the market so the market is going to
remain time
Germany currently has no LNG terminals
five are planned but until they're ready
it will be dependent on European
neighbors with that prices are likely to
stay high and Germany might find itself
making political concessions to others
in order to satisfy its energy needs
for more I'm joined by DW political
correspondent Benjamin Alvarez Gruber
Ben how difficult a political Balancing
Act is the chancellor facing in Saudi
Arabia it is indeed a very difficult
um thing that they have to somehow
manage of course government officials
have been telling us that human rights
issues will be addressed during this
trip in the three countries but it's
still striking to see the German
Chancellor shaking hands with a Saudi
Crown Prince um Mohammed bin Salman who
has been accused by U.S official of
ordering the murder of um yamal
khashoggi for journalist a few years ago
but the relationship between the west
and Saudi Arabia has been normalizing
over the past month with see many
leaders visiting the country we had
French president Emmanuel macron we had
U.S President Joe Biden and that was
interesting because only a few years ago
he said that he would make sure to treat
Saudi Arabia as a pariah State and then
he even had a fist bump with the Crown
Prince so that is something that many
have been criticizing also criticizing
with this trip and if we look at Germany
there's also another big topic that is
arms a embargo in arms embargo that they
imposed after the war in Yemen also what
happened to yamal khashoggi and the
question that we just heard there what
would Berlin do if we had also says this
is a requirement for us to lift the
Embargo that's something that asked
German officials yesterday and they
dodged the question so it definitely
shows how difficult this trip is but
also how important it is for Germany to
find additional Partners now they want
to turn their backs on Russia energy
supplies what else is on the agenda on
this golf tour so the focus will be
energy but the business delegation that
is joining the chancellor is not only in
the area of energy it's also here in
space Fair it's also engineering so we
have a very big delegation he will then
travel to the United Arab Emirates he
will continue his trip to Qatar a
country that the vice Chancellor and
economy Minister Robert visited earlier
this year and that's what he wanted to
sign this deal of liquefied natural
gases LNG terminals that Chancellor
Schultz has spoken about several times
they'll have several meetings with
officials there there will be no press
briefing at all also no opportunity for
the press to ask them what they can do
the focus will be on energy to see how
they can work the vice Chancellor
sounded pretty confident that there will
be New Deals now but of course it is a
difficult topic for them and there have
been human rights organizations also
politicians belonging to the position
saying that he should raise this issue
also when we look at Qatar where the
world's soccer World Cup will happen in
November so definitely a difficult trip
for them
two-day trip let's see and what these
Partnerships will look like a busy
German Chancellor over the course of the
next few days and a consequential trip
at that that's DW's Benjamin Alvarez
Gruber many thanks